foreign
time I was homeless instead of going
home every night there was no home to go
to life at home was very difficult I
grew up being abused
I lost my belt I lost respect I
embarrassed my family I think it was
pretty much non-existent I was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
I come out I have Supreme confidence and
I'm scared to death
afraid of everything I didn't care about
living I just wanted to die I got up and
I felt the way to the world was lifted
off my shoulders I knew I was going to
make a comeback
fighting this was designed for me to do
what makes us who we are
thank you
I'm so far ahead of the game
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
I have always been a fighter there's
nothing I do better than just laughing
fighting there ain't never been a lot
come back to me I was born to do this
nobody can get close I'm the best
fighter in the world I'm the most brutal
and ambitious
yeah
welcome back to the pain game podcast
with my brother in arms Wade how are you
doing brother all right what's up man
how are you man I'm good Merry Christmas
by the way yeah you see it I'm not
feeling the Vibes I'm ready I told
myself this year I'm not letting anyone
get their treat before I do so I was
ready December one I was not playing
around bro I love it I love it I mean me
and we talk all the time so we don't
really need to go through the whole like
this because women was talking
um this past weekend UFC uh the stock of
Paddy pimlet took a battering in the
last week like and you know I'm very
friendly with this guy I wouldn't say
I'm his best friend or anything but I
had him on my show pre-ufc and he went
up against uh Ariel helwani he's best
game to play yeah it to be fair it went
worse for him against Ariel helwani than
it did for him in the up they're gone
against
um that Jared
so let's take out or take on the aerial
helwani situation first because I have
something in common with Ariel helwani
I had Paddy on my show pre-ufc
and then when he got into the UFC I was
also told by his manager it's gonna cost
you if you want him back on uh so that
was quite uh interesting and uh I did I
did make a few notes because I don't
want to [__] this up
um yeah I remember watching Ariel I
think like 2008 like that's how far back
Ariel's been doing this so I got to give
it up to him I do have respect for him
he took Paddy apart in a very easy
fashion because Paddy is not as skilled
with his words as what Ariel is Ariel
has it's like Paddy and Ariel rolling
Jiu Jitsu you know like it wouldn't be
fair and it's the same with Ariel and um
but I think the broad point that Paddy
made that Ariel makes money off the
fighters has some weight to it and I
think that the the way Ariel sort of
took it is a very literal thing of well
I don't get paid for YouTube abuse it's
like well
the company who pays your contract
they're literally budget based on what
views you're going to bring to them and
the the reason Ariel's built his star up
over a decade or more even is through
having the star power rub off on him
from Fighters and from all of those
appearances and it all factors in when
you're budgeting to have Ariel helwani
sign a contract with you so to say he
doesn't make any money off of Fighters
you know it's like okay you don't have
your own YouTube channel but the YouTube
channel you work for literally does make
money off of sponsors and Views and they
get that from your interview so right I
felt like he was slightly disingenuous
in the way he explained it he made it
out like he was some sort of 1980s
newspaper journalist and that's not what
he is he's he is slightly an Entertainer
and he is on YouTube and right you know
so I just wanted to start off by saying
I was gonna say yeah like what what
Ariel does well is and it was what made
him into I guess what you would call a
star as an MMA Journey is he's been able
to blend a combination of breaking news
stories real hard-hitting journalism
things that the UFC I mean you've seen
why they don't like him he blew up the
Brock Lesnar story and again that was
one that that like he gets a bad rap for
that he was doing exactly what he was
supposed to do there yeah and the UFC
supposedly had this hit like don't say
it don't he didn't know he went and did
his job so a journalist is supposed to
challenge authority and Ariel's done
that well many times many times and he
has that that that option even now he
can still do that and he still does that
he still is the major news breaking
Source
sorry to interrupt your word what I will
say is he hasn't quite challenged
let's say Conor McGregor in the same way
when he's been sat in front of Conor
McGregor who has a whole host of things
you could rip the shreds on Ariel has
been very careful in those interviews
and sometimes it's not been great
interviews because he's been so careful
and the reason he's been so careful is
because he doesn't want to [__] up the
money now he plays a very clever game in
the way he's gone at Dana as our sort of
Robin Hood but it it ain't always that
way you know and I think that there's
been opportunities missed spiral where
he's been sat in front of the fighter so
he could have taken apart you know and
and I I'm not I don't want to criticize
him because I have so much respect for
him but I think just the way he laid out
was for maximum damage against Paddy uh
because he was so upset by what was said
and I think he's gonna say and and I get
that he's upset because Paddy spoke
about him in a really bad way and I
don't think that was right but what I
want to do is sort of bring a little bit
more of a level-headed unrealistic
approach to this because we're not
involved so it's easier yeah it was it
was easy for Ariel to slam dunk on Patty
absolutely very easy like Patty made it
easier by just saying the things he said
but you are right Ariel did approach
this as an emotional guy to a degree
right and this is something I didn't
bring up in my video and I probably
should have you look at Ariel as a guy
that is an unbiased journalist but he's
still a human being right he is still a
guy with feelings and a guy that maybe
sometimes wears those on his sleeve a
little
um that's what happened here yeah you
should be like you said he's a content
creator as well right he's still going
to offer opinions now where that line is
met to where he is over stepping in and
saying things that are maybe not in
school like you shouldn't be saying some
of the things that Patty kind of opened
the door for though so it's like you
kind of just you have to you have to put
out the truth but Ariel could have
approached this and and to be fair I
think did for a long time as a way of
being like listen I'm not gonna say this
I have all this info we're not going to
bring it out but the fighter pay issue
like him coming on the show all that
Ariel said it himself I I just saw
something I do you know other people can
do that but the way Ariel read into it
with the manager saying oh let's do
something you're gonna have to pay get
your budget and Ariel being so offended
is that emotional side of it right yeah
yeah that's the point yeah I think a lot
of people are sort of missing that
because Paddy was so reckless it's easy
to blame party for this but well I I
just wanted to dissect it a bit deeper
because
um just because Ariel does make money
off a Fighters and I have made many many
pounds of Fighters I am completely
admitting that I do this also but but
they benefit from it too because the
what what an Ariel helwani is there to
do is help a fighter tell his story
better than he can and that's why he
deserves compensated for this so at no
point am I saying that Ariel is doing
fight as over and I think that for party
to sit there in front of Dana White and
accusing of that was out of order
um and I think what Ariel has created
saying it is hilarious yeah of all
people to say that the guy who's
literally the American Tory
um but I think what Ariel has created
and what other podcasters have created
our interviewers is is like especially
Ariel is an ecosystem where Ariel didn't
have used the Conor McGregor's the big
boys but he also interviews the small
Fighters and that trickle down is
benefiting those the whole community of
MMA so to say he's purely there a suck
and take from it and not give anything
back I think is really unfair on Ariel
um so um just just to break down some of
the other things that was said by these
guys Paddy's saying Ariel wanted me to
do a free interview instead of a paid
interview that my manager had lined up I
think that's that's a very convenient
you know way to put it to try and
deflect from the the asking for money
for the the interview that's exactly
what it is yeah like an Ariel came out
and said he's like I didn't say you
couldn't go do another interview like I
don't control what you do just fit me in
as well for free if you can like just no
that's not gonna be what we do here the
money jump of Paddy Graham uh incredibly
short-sighted when when you because what
they've tried to do now is they've gone
no we weren't asking Ariel for money we
were just asking if he could ask BT for
money and I'm like I asked for you for
an interview from you at the same time
I'm not employed by BT and you ask me
for money as well so that's [__]
that is flat out [__] from Paddy's
manager and this guy
I know people who know of him and and
look he's clearly done certain things of
worth in his career but I I I and I get
that he's there to make money for Paddy
but when you're also getting a
percentage of that money you may make
decisions that aren't worth hurting your
Fighter's reputation for an extra few
quid if you've got that small time
mentality and this was small time for me
yeah this turned into a way bigger thing
than it should have been and what
happens now is and again you're right
Graham you know deciding to I guess use
this as the platform he wanted to go at
aerial right you don't go with the big
guy like you can even going at you like
you're gonna start to build a reputation
for people that don't want to work with
you and Patty is now unfortunately kind
of receiving that same hate that really
he is just writing for his manager right
like Patty is is hearing a lot of things
in his ear and his manager obviously is
the guy that knows more about this stuff
yeah Arrow even said it when he when he
reached out he goes hey I let Graham do
a lot of that stuff now like I don't
know how all this works I just let him
do it and then whatever he says I do so
it's obviously Patty listening to
somebody probably is the guy you know
and it's like
a little too much heat this week I feel
like really it's the guy behind putty
who should be taking more of the flock
and then think about it how many how
many fighters know how to Manny like
navigate this space how many guys know
where I should be how I should be doing
it when like not a lot Conor is probably
the only one should this be somebody
should be doing that for them but they
should just be good at it yeah and
that's the thing Graham's probably very
good at his job but again you pick your
battles here you don't go and you know
try to Big League Ariel hawani and then
when it all hits the fan Patty's the one
that's trying to ride for his managers
manager to step through his hands up he
didn't say anything and then did you see
that did you see that Instagram video
yeah bro yeah managers are usually very
good at speaking this was a [__]
shambles of the video right so but what
I will say the only thing I could say
against Ariel outside of the incorrect
point he made about not making money off
of Fighters was when he got emotional in
the DMS and took issue with the being
charged I thought if you just leave this
here and you go okay fair enough you
want to charge I'm I'm not going to pay
fair enough I'll see you later if he
just left it at that and didn't start
getting a little bit aggressive in those
DMS and then goes on the Pat McAfee show
and blatantly indirect's party I feel
like Ariel has not conceded that he
could have handled that bit better yet
yeah that to me when you know you've got
a young lad from Liverpool who doesn't
play politics who is just going to speak
his mind
you're saying well I never said your
name it's like bro he knows you're
talking about him though exactly I don't
know and I do think Ariel as the
uh wise uh uh guy in this situation
who's an old older journalist who's been
around just could have just not if he if
Ariel doesn't say anything there in that
moment none of this happens by the way
that that's it dead
um so I do think Ariel has sort of and I
get it when someone comes after you
you're not going to concede anything but
for us I think we can say he could have
just not
you could have handled that better going
on Pat McAfee show and doing that
granted 99 of people who would have had
no idea what he was talking about but
the people that mattered and the reason
this thing blew up didn't because as
soon as that happened Graham gets on
Instagram writes that long message about
how Fighters can get paid and that's
where people made the connection now
what Ariel and and this is not me
defending area let's just be watching
him over the last couple of years Ariel
for years we've watched him he was a
background quiet guy never talked about
like the beef between him and other
people and then when that Dana thing
happened it switched very quickly right
like you saw him get emotional the whole
thing but now he is he'll want he he's
coming for skulls man he buried Brendan
Shaw buried him like 10-7 him over
something that again didn't really need
to be said between either of them but
Ariel was really adamant about taking
like umbrage with what he said and
making sure everyone knew it it seems
like that's the way Ariel's gonna handle
things and it is fairly emotional in
some cases and I think this was one of
of those cases where I don't know where
he got offended so much by was the fact
that he was asked I think or yeah I've
got all respect for Ariel defending
himself but when you're all about the
truth when you're all about the truth
and and Ariel is generally that way
inclined you have to reflect that on
yourself and your own behavior and I
just think he could have taken a little
more accountability than he did and it
yeah and and that's all I'm saying like
yeah you know at the end of the day what
she said we're completely out of order
what day and I said were out of order
and it's easy for me to say Ariel could
have been a little less emotional but
it's not me they're talking about and I
understand he he was pissed yeah um and
you are right though if it's between
Ariel and you know a younger fighter
that really probably doesn't know how to
navigate this space in that moment Ariel
could have and probably should have said
you know what I this is silly I don't
need to go public and say some stuff
like this and then yeah never like you
said it never would have happened they
would have still had beef between them
whatever but it never would have been
this they could have easily walked this
yeah like when I got the when I got the
message from my guy saying oh they've
asked for money I just went ah believe
it then exactly and that was it dead
nothing came of it you know what I mean
because I get it like party's a young
guy from Liverpool and they don't know
how long this is going to last so they
might be trying to get as much cash in
while they can before this [__] blows or
whatever fair play to them I understand
that and as a man how am I going to have
a problem with another guy for trying to
make as much money as he can in that
event so I see both sides and I I think
I I but I get Ariel's broader point
about as a business a journalist if they
had to pay for every single [__]
interview they did that would kill the
business so on a broader level what
Ariel although he's taken it very
personally I think what he's fighting
for is is the right thing which is we
shouldn't have to pay for interviews
just don't do the interview if you don't
want to do the interview you know what I
mean right no Ariel's correct by by
saying what he said and not only the
payment you know killing the business in
in a financial sake but also in an
Integrity state where Ariel yes he has
interviews with guys like Connor where
you want to see him push the envelope a
little more but it eliminates it
completely when you're buying interviews
because at that point you're not buying
just the interview you're buying the
questions you ask you're buying the
responses you get you're buying the time
of that individual so it becomes a
pattern of oh okay I I know what's going
on here here comes the softball question
I'm very comfortable with this guy so
that's that's exactly what happens he
literally got paid to do gigs with Conor
McGregor on stage remember whether he
did that to us so like Ariel's taking
money to bathe interviewer before by the
way I got I doubt he did that for free
maybe he did fair enough
um do you want to know which two people
asked me to pay for them uh other than
paddy
let me try to guess uh the furies no
actually I I said no so they've never
appeared okay and they both asked for
the same amount of money I believe okay
one was Floyd Money Mayweather
you gotta love it you gotta love it
one was Ric Flair
no way I know we're in the wrestling
game right you love wrestling we're
going to talk about wrestling at the end
of this actually because I know you're
getting into your wrestling content yes
how much do you think they quoted me
Floyd at the same number
same number 50 G's it was 10. okay
10 G's bro yeah 10 G's for Floyd
Mayweather but no I I mean I kind of get
it from for Ric Flair yeah like I love
Rick Mage is crazy but come on son yeah
I was like that's I'd love to interview
Ric Flair don't get me wrong but I
haven't got that kind of money
[__] no I'm attend Jesus I ain't
gonna recoup that investment either not
on Floyd even
oh
so yeah bro I mean let's talk about
parties in in cage performance yeah uh
who did you give the fight to
uh Jerry Gordon easily
um oh wow it could have been it could
have been 30 27 Jared Gordon to be
honest with you um I I had it 29-28 I
thought
um God I have to go back and watch I
think it was Patty winning the second
Jared Gordon easily in my opinion went
into first
um and and the third round I don't see
how you give to Patty I know that MMA
judging has become so subjective and I
don't want to turn this into a full like
breakdown of MMA judging but you know a
guy gets held on the cage for for damn
near five minutes and granted there's
not a lot of of damage being put on
Patty in those moments and damage is
something that apparently is very much
now uh the Forefront of judging in MMA
again it's a subjective word what what
is damage like what's the significant
strike medium hard strike Light Strike
what what is the damage right do you see
a guy get cut and they're like ah he
wins the round because this guy got to
cut on his head like like what are you
talking about so yeah I I had uh Gordon
win in the first round again you know
Patty has this this ability that that we
all know that he has on his grappling
game he has apparently a granite chin
but he has flaws he has big big flaws in
his striking big flaws in his striking
defense and that came out again the left
hook whenever Jared Gordon wanted to
land it he did the amount of times we've
seen that blown wig pop back flies yeah
and if there's one thing uh Vidal taught
me when obviously I was in the ring with
him for those times he said if you keep
making the same mistake I'm gonna
[__] hurt you you know like and and
so will a proper fighter and that was
the thing that when Paddy kept making
that same mistake of no head movement
hands down chin in the air I thought any
any top 15 fighter or anyone with some
real power in their hands they're going
to really put putty in some serious
serious trouble because this guy was not
ranked no and it was not a a high level
guy but this is the thing for me I'm I'm
questioning Paddy's instincts in a as a
standard fighter is when you keep
getting hit with the same shot and you
keep allowing that to happen over in
multiple rounds and you're not
registering I need to change what I'm
doing it tells me that you're not
thinking enough you're also not prepared
enough and you haven't learned enough
when you're getting in there and when
he's been taught like people like Teddy
Atlas have
literally told him like you need to
[__] sort that out now and his
attitude is that suck me [__] like
that that's what I was gonna say it's
not attitude I'm like you know when the
the day comes when someone checks in
properly that scouse says Don't get
knocked out clip will be played on
repeat a hundred percent because you you
you just can't fight like that on any
level so you you just said it's the
attitude of Patty like the reason we
love him is also the reason we're
starting to see he's gonna have a cap
here there's going to be a limit on what
Patty can be it's it's gonna be because
of him himself right he is
unapologetically just this way like when
they ask him about chin up hands down he
goes this is how I fight what do you
mean like he just doesn't care like he
just does not care it's it's the way
he's gonna fight it seems like there's
no caution to the wind at all as far as
getting hit but again he hasn't been hit
and cracked and hurt like a guy like
Ilia tapora could do to him oh God the
fact that they had that beef in the pre
uh the press conference and then to
poorer gets in there puts on a clinic
looks like a Savage you're like [__]
getting in there with him buddy stay
away from this guy now and if the UFC is
smart they they saw I mean the clip has
been run now for I don't know how many
times on Twitter of Dana White looking
at the bar stool guys and there's some
trepidation in that face he didn't know
what that decision was going to be which
is again shocking that it was even a a
close decision to me you know when you
talk about the Boston moment that really
that whole bar still thing when he comes
out that
I mean those guys I I don't know what
they like in America how big they are I
know their football content is dog [__]
like they have the worst football [__]
like possible they have not a clue mate
like it's embarrassing what they've done
um yeah they're massive over here but
yeah they are they are have no idea when
it comes to the the football side and
really quite frankly the fight side yeah
okay so so this is the thing this could
have been how you play this like sugar
Shawn when he got his close decision you
know he can play it well or you can be
like when he's going today in a fight of
the night
you're like are you [__] me me what
what planet are you on that was a very
average fight like bro did you hear him
talking to Joe Rogan the first thing he
does
with his big moment after his win his
controversial win he goes yo did you pay
for this interview really got a favor
it's a it's a good line but then he goes
but it's a good line if if that's not
true the problem is if it is a joke
Joe no salt and he was like yeah all
right whatever dude Jordan give a [__]
did he no he doesn't get one bit but
then he goes uh you know sorry Patty
this was a close fight what are your
thoughts and Patty interrupts him he's
like no it wasn't close I won the first
two easy coaster in the third I was like
what you're saying is awful one that you
thought you won easily and two that you
said you just posted in the third yeah I
was like I was watching Luke Thomas and
he said something along the lines of uh
you know people have compared the sky to
Conor McGregor which I think is such an
unfair comparison to be fair to Paddy
like this guy is the biggest star in the
history of the sport and had in a
meteoric rise like we'd never seen
before but he was like his fourth UFC
fight was Dustin Poirier ranked number
five dusted him in the first round like
this um this guy
um Gordon is not even ranked and you're
struggling in a decision with him like
reality check and I think that's what we
expected it was a bit of a a moment of
reality of okay it was a tough fight I
need to work on my stand but it was just
completely not a easy win I just costed
the third row yeah I just posted the
third because I dominated the first two
it's unbelievable again it's it's
Patty's mindset and his attitude he
genuinely is in his mind bigger more
talented bigger superstar than he really
is right now and that's not a knock on
Jared Gordon by the way the guy's 19-6
like he's a legitimate good talented
fighter but he's just not the type
there's so many above him that are
better than him that's where you go okay
and that was my takeaway was [__] the
decision it's this is this is where your
level is right now you're not ready for
those top guys and you've had a big
speed bump here and it's time to to live
from because probably he has got Elite
Jujitsu but everything else needs work
basically well that was the thing too
that we didn't even get to see it really
in this fight he destroyed like
grappling for grappling Jared Gordon a
decent wrestler was kind of like putting
Patty where he wanted him on that cage
and he was like you're not getting off
it unless you do something here and
again this is more of an MMA judging
thing with me it's like if we're gonna
call this third round a bad strategy
which is hilarious from Dana to say in
the post fight presser he's like that
was a terrible strategy in the third you
know what would make that an easy
strategy big Dana if we had open scoring
in MMA and you could see where you were
going into the third yeah what about
Darren till real quick because
um obviously
another defeat we've got yeah I I
watched Court Daniel Cormier and I watch
Michael Bisping obviously best being
good friend Bisping saying there's
plenty Darren can do you know it was a
tough opponent and he's speaking quite
positively Daniel Cormier said I can't
see him last so much longer
Daniel come here is like retirement
that's what he's talking about yeah I
mean listen it's it's more Daniel
Cormier being right here than bismi in
my opinion and not that they're both
completely right like this means right
when he says Darren still got something
in the tank but it's just like man when
you watched air until fight over the
last five years have we seen a different
dare until in any fight have we seen a
different guy man you've made a great
point because one of the quotes I wrote
down from Bisping was not enough output
mental block and I thought mayor that's
Darren till he hasn't looked dominant in
a single fight he's had since Donald
Cerrone the two wins he's had were close
as [__] and the rest weren't obviously
you lost them and and in fact out of the
last I don't know four fights I think
he's been finished three times or
something like that so it's it's just as
much as we all lie down I think all five
fans have a like a like uh for Darren
it's absolutely the reality needs to be
there and there needs to be some harsh
reality of how the [__] are you training
with kamzat jamai give and your
wrestling defense is like it was bad man
it was like dupless had one way to win
that fight really and it was to grab a
hold of Darren and smash him on the
ground and that's what he did for that
first entire round fair play today and
he's a tough tough dude oh he took it
well like yeah yeah yeah but it's like
the one way you know you can lose this
fight is the one thing that you needed
to work on and that's why you're with
hamzajimayev and that's why you're with
those guys you know working your
grappling and still just there's a
misconnect there and then when Darren
does get to his feet the spot where he
is supposed to run this guy over be an
absolute freight train it's just like he
cannot push it into that third gear you
just cannot let whatever he has in the
tank go and I'm not exactly sure what
round two uh well duplessis was gustis
first yo just like bro kill him go after
him he is Gus and Darren is in this like
I think you quote tweeted uh Luke
Thomas's point about oh my God he just
looks like he's in sparring mode
constantly
it's like I need to kill this
[__] there's every time I watch
Darren fight and all of Eve at the
gasoline win uh Wonder Boy win it's
always like he's I don't know if he's
hesitant he's always thinking about
what's coming back and not thinking
about killing the other guy something
that you see with Darren too even in the
wins and by the way the Kelvin gaslin
win is a huge win on his resume
but even in those fights you see a guy
that wants to be technically better it
looks like when he fights he wants to be
technically better than you so he is
very much let me pick my shot Let Me
Line this thing up let me hit you with
one to open up everything else and then
sometimes that's just if you're there
until you're a big strong guy give us
some variety give us some volume right
work your way to that big shot because
if it's not the back elbow and it's not
the lead hand pull down straight left
hand I gotta be honest I don't know what
else Darren has
nowhere near varied enough yeah you know
I haven't shown us that ever by the
others me because I know he's a talented
guy and he says all the right things and
mentality is different than just saying
it you have to be able to go and believe
the things that you're saying I just
don't know if he does anymore I thought
that this was going to be a real reality
check moment for him and then he pulls
this thing on his Instagram about like
all these pictures of his previous fight
scene I'm just getting started and I I'm
just like you need a serious chat with
someone who's gonna keep it [__] real
with you right now and first of all I
probably got someone like a Jason
Perillo you know bisping's got that got
that connector he needs a head coach who
knows how to make Champions because all
of this woman is in Thailand one minute
he's with uh the The Lads at Coban one
minute he's with comes out like he's all
over the shop and he's all over the shop
in his head he needs one coach one
message and one team and that's it you
know what I mean and uh and Michael
Bisping might be the one to put him in
touch with him hopefully and now him in
85 he looks small so it's like you got
to make that decision too and it's going
to be like you said it needs to be a
real reality check he's 31 years old
um time is not on his side here this is
a Young Man sport especially at both
those divisions we have guys springing
up left and right and God forbid he gets
in there with a bow nickel or somebody
that they toss him in with it doesn't
look like he's in these problems you
know I think he said he sorry I think he
said he's 29 coming on 30 this Christmas
or something like that yeah he doesn't
have that spring in that like I don't
know if it's all of the the ways
tretta's body the injuries or what but
he doesn't he's not looking like the guy
in his prime when he came on the scene
in welterweight he was explosive and he
was you know just murking guys and again
you know competition is going to breed
exactly what your level is and maybe
this whole time we just thought Darren
was a higher level than he genuinely is
I think that's the case if I'm being
honest I think I think we have to
believe the data and yeah you know what
I mean like you're getting finished by
like three guys in your last four
defeats for example and that's a fighter
in Decline usually so or the all the
competition is getting better as you
said let's let's talk YouTube boxing
them because uh you've been you've been
coming out with some really interesting
stuff lately about the business of
YouTube boxing and I I wanted to pick
your brain on where this is going right
now because you put out a story recently
about Gabe and his uh fee demands to
fight on a design card which blew my
[__] mind right there was a I think
if I'm writing and correct me if I'm
wrong he rejected quarter of a million
to fight on a design card and it's a
shame because I've really been wanting
to see how he would do against some of
the guys that have sprung into life uh
through Misfits I'm talking slim salt
puppy we would love to see those fights
um is that where it's at right now I
mean yeah yeah it's a crazy number isn't
it it's it's Madness just just for
example no just so people understand
though who maybe are I don't know well I
just cleared up UFC fighters no like I
think Tyron Woodley his last paycheck in
the UFC for example when he was a former
Champion right not not you know top
level guy was quarter of a million I
think something in that region so if
Gabe is rejecting that that shows the
kind of cash this guy has been making at
and good for him love the guys exactly
but wow yeah that's the thing is is
we're getting to this point and it
saddens me because it it we're getting
to it but it's almost like we're
evolving into the pro scene where we're
not gonna get some of the fights we want
because of silly little stuff like this
but it's it's also you know twofold
because if you're Gibb why would you
fight for whatever the number is less
because we don't know what how much less
because he said it was his lowest offer
in the last three years we don't know
how much less that offer is so I bet
yeah I paid good money I know right so
if you give why would you right and and
here's another thing that we're we're
still dealing with in the in the YouTube
boxing scene while Misfits is becoming
the biggest player in town they're still
not the only one so if some guy or some
company has enough money to toss around
and they want to get their son's
favorite influencer on a card or
something you know it's a possibility
that he can still go out and make that
money which is why he's not signing with
Misfits right now that makes I mean the
most sense to me originally we were
getting all of these fights that we
wanted and now we're starting to see
people are currently avoiding the
assault puppy avoiding slim KSI posted
recently like just getting these guys
fights is becoming difficult it's a
combination of things it's uh you know
obviously the danger involved with
fighting AI like salt poppy which his
fight with Bruckner would love that but
it's also you know the risk reward
factor for a lot of guys they're
starting to smarten themselves up to the
business and when they see Gibb now
being offered that kind of money this is
the scary part you got guys that are
aren't as talented as Gibb that maybe
have the same social media following see
that number and and go wait why am I
fighting for whatever the number is less
than that why am I not yeah because
you're getting paid not based on your
boxing ability or getting paid on how
much money you draw simple as that
exactly and here's the sad thing and I'm
not here to to you know look at anyone's
pockets and pocket watch anything like
that but let's be honest with ourselves
how many people are drawing anywhere
close to an amount that that would allow
them to make 250 000 exactly there's not
made there's maybe three yeah so if
we're really gonna look at this as a
business and something that has to go
forward I'm not saying Fighters don't go
get your money because go get your money
100 whatever you can get whatever you
can make do it I'm all about it but we
also have to be realistic if we're
looking at this as a long-term play for
Misfits for MVP for whatever companies
pop up they have to run this as a
business and to my knowledge Misfits has
been profitable over their four over the
three that they've had and now with the
fourth one we'll see but they've come
out on top in these so they're doing
something right it's just Fighters are
going to have to really think about what
do I want out of this am I trying to
become is this my new career path or am
I trying to make a quick buck and do my
thing and then hop off because if that's
the case fair play go get your money but
if we're if we want these fights if we
want give and slim someone's gonna have
to come to a compromise and that is the
fight it's given slim uh I'd love that
fight for real that's the one man yeah
that's the one yeah let's talk about the
next Misfits card then so starting at
the top KSI versus Dylan Dennis your boy
uh yeah Dylan uh yeah I've had a little
bit of uh back and forth with this guy
he's quite a funny guy
you
there's a lot of people who say [__]
about me and I just I feel nothing like
I I still watch their videos and I still
I don't get uh Ariel helwani about it
yeah it's the game I get the game and he
plays it and I'm cool with it and good
for him you know and he's getting paid I
hope he shows up
um and and luckily they've got some good
fighters on the undercard and I really
hope that if he does drop out they give
it to a slim assault puppy they don't
just go and get an out of shape t-word
or something like that you know this
well they do have Joe Fournier on the
card and that has to be for a reason
right like Joe Fournier not a big
influencer
um
random billionaire isn't he yeah he's
like he did some real estate stuff and
owned a couple gyms but he he is 9-0
right he's good friends with David Haye
they had the little Place bar for
triller but he is a guy that's been
rumored to be possible opponent for KSI
so him being on the car makes me think
okay they have a contingency plan in
case still it falls out Joe is there
kind of I'm kind of failing like Misfits
it's it's becoming something else and I
understand why you know the business
needs to have levels and layers to it
there they've got fallback options but
initially it was influencer boxing now
it's just random guys who box like like
that that that guy that rich guy fonia
uh California yeah yeah like he he an
influence out of my knowledge and
there's a lot of other people who are
getting in there like MMA fighters and
and like when when that MMA guy um that
big beast of a man the heavyweight went
in there with uh oh Jesus you mean Greg
Hardy Greg Hardy yeah uh when when he
got in there with um rotman Jr I thought
oh you done [__] up with this
matchmaking because you probably signed
Ruckman Jr on a damn good contract and
you're about a [__] got right up the
wall because Greg Hardy is just going to
put him right in this place oh great it
was it was insane watching Greg Hardy
I've seen him for I've known about him
for forever he's a high level NFL guy
yeah um obviously got in some trouble
and then did the UFC thing but yeah he
got in some bad trouble but he is uh
he's a guy that's just a higher level
athlete and watching him at 100 plus
pounds do what he did to Rockman he's
another guy what what you're saying
though makes sense like they are taking
that next step away from just influencer
boxing this is why anytime you hear me
with the Zone with Misfits the words are
a crossover boxing right they are really
trying to make this a whatever celebrity
from whatever you know football NBA uh
actor uh real estate whatever they can
find a
Wayman Jr fits into that when the guy is
actually a boxer fights an MMA guy then
loses like that's where you [__] up
like yeah whoever decided on that [__]
up that one's tough because Rock and
that's another thing I think Misfits
wants to do rock was could be a guy that
you could Champion as the pro boxer and
you know there's another fight on this
card that we have another Pro Idris
Virgo on the card and if Misfits wants
to to throw their name in the Hat of pro
boxing arena these are the guys they're
gonna do it behind because you're not
gonna do it behind the influencers
you're not gonna do it behind the MMA
guys that are boxing if they want that
yes the matchmaking and again we have to
remember Rock was supposed to fight uh
Vitor which was a completely different
fight and then unfortunately that one
that one fell out though right you think
you're fighting old man Vito Bell fog
who's gonna cruise to a victory and then
they bring out the Incredible Hulk and
they're like yeah you're up buddy like
what the [__] I can't believe he agreed
to do that such a mistake apparently
from what I heard it was rocks like he
was adamant on doing it like he was like
yeah like loved the challenge but I
think it was some that if I had talked
to rock now he'd probably be like oh I
didn't know oh that was what Drake
already was
he was taking rutman's shots as if they
were nothing man just eating them sorry
so so back to the Dylan KSI fight where
you know we're we're um
I'm excited for this but not really
excited in terms of I I don't have that
will KSI lose feeling and I think that
that's a bit of a mistake on the part of
the promotion
um however I I understand that you know
it it is a step up from swarms and
Panera yeah so okay we we've stepped up
and I give them credit for that I think
the only danger I see in this fight
personally is if KSI doesn't look good
that's the danger here and yeah I think
on one of your videos if I'm writing
thinking that there is a danger of that
because of Dylan's awkwardness and his
background yeah anytime you fight a guy
and I'll say this the the promotion
getting Dylan again they were put I
think they were put in a bad spot
because of what happened to Logan Logan
was gonna fight Dylan this was 100 gonna
be the fight yeah
um and when that fell out you have again
guys like T wood probably and I can't
confirm this but probably asking for a
number that they can't justify without a
Logan Paul on the card uh so contracts
and things like that but when you do
have Dylan I think there's a threat of a
couple things yes there's a threat of
him making KSI look less than he is
right less than he can look against a
professional boxer or someone that's
more polished and that's because Dylan
is going to be like you said awkward
he's going to be able to I assume in
certain exchanges in clinches do things
that KSI is not used to right even if
KSI is at shoot Fighters Dylan just has
a Mastery of grappling position this is
the same thing I know I said it in the
Ben Oscar fight with Jake but this is
the same thing that you would you would
suspect a jiu jitsu grappling guy to do
when he comes into boxing close range
with some wild [__] punches that don't
look great but the point is not to make
those punches look great it's the close
distance to get to the places where he's
comfortable that's the danger in
fighting a guy like Dylan KSI gets tied
up it becomes one of those fights or the
crowds booing things don't necessarily
look as flashy that he want him to see
and if he doesn't that is where you know
even if with a win that is where we
leave ourselves going well did we really
learn anything again that's the hard
part yeah Dylan is not on the level of a
Tyrone Woodley so
um
and and for that reason
JJ and I'm sure he will hold himself to
the standards of what Jake did to Ben
askren it's got to be a quick
annihilation in there and I think um
from what I've seen of of Dylan's uh
hard work and his limited boxing that
I've watched very little power it would
be my my first comment uh I don't think
he's got enough to push JJ back I think
JJ will be walking him down quite
quickly and probably doing that smiling
and clowning while he's slapping him up
but there needs to be like a seriousness
I think like a a viciousness where it's
yes I've got to make a statement and get
you out of here because so far the Logan
fights were very difficult for obvious
reasons it's Logan and Logan's a
difficult challenge but in Panera and
swarms because those guys were so [__]
it was hard to look good against them we
need a good clean finish and we need
something where we can hold that up and
go he's on the right path that's what we
want to see if we don't get a
devastating finish where it looks clean
then I think JJ will feel like he's
failed himself in that moment yeah and
that's the thing that I think everyone
including JJ knows like he knows this is
that one where he has to make a
statement and if that statement isn't
made we're just gonna still sit here and
go oh man like what how do we get this
Jake and KSI fight because that's the
one everyone wants how do we get to that
because we don't know not that even that
JJ is not ready whatever we just don't
know if you if we can't see we don't
know and this is why I I picked Ben
against Jake because I didn't know we
hadn't seen what we had gotten from Jake
until that moment we're like oh
this is what he is yeah the AJ needs the
same type of performance and when you
talked about him coming forward I'll
caution people that are going to watch
this fight with it needs to be composed
JJ has to be a composed killer in there
not emotional not letting the the
windmills fly whatever it is this needs
to be composed slick confident just like
we've seen from Jake as he's progressed
as he's gotten better the boxing's
gotten tighter JJ needs to do that
because walking forward on a Grappler if
you miss one of those big bangs he's
going to wrap you up double under Hooks
and you're going to tussle for about 30
seconds till the referee stops it yeah
what's going to happen if he's not
composed even even though swarms and
Panera were no no real threat and I I
get JJ could get relaxed and he could
throw the game plan out the window
because he knew I'm way better than
these guys
boxing friends of mine watched that and
said look I we get that he's not you
know treating them with the respect that
he should be and and try but but what
we're seeing was still a little bit on
the on the rough and sloppier side than
what you'd want it to be and that's what
I'm talking about with this fight is
yeah it needs to be taken super
seriously even if you're way better than
Dylan you know that's irrelevant it's
you're making him a statement out with
this guy so that it's believable that
you are on the level of Jake and that
we're seeing that progress that's the
thing is JJ's not fighting opponents
anymore he's fighting whatever the
progression is to Jake right that's
that's what it is like the opponents are
irrelevant you have to go in and perform
in a way that makes us believe that
you're ready for Jake and that's not
that sucks for him to be honest that
really sucks because he can't just go in
and win a fight and be proud of it like
Jake already made this path he can't
even go in and win and be like yeah look
what I did I'm evolving he now has to go
and fight what Jake did to get to where
Jake's at that's the hard part out of
all of the
um contenders that we're seeing in
Misfits from uh Kenny uh obviously Papi
uh slim even Gabe If he if he jumps in
there and any others
who do you think is most likely to get a
fight with KSI
oh man I I also I don't mean who
deserves I mean who would they give the
fight to because sometimes they might go
not him yet you know what I mean yeah
yeah no I I that's the hard part I don't
think
salt Poppy's getting that fight anytime
soon
um and I think we all know why because
that means why is that he's dangerous
right the risk reward factor of fighting
poppy right now is not something that
makes sense for Jason the following to
be uh
and and lose to Poppy and people like me
and you will be like damn that was like
JJ took on probably the hardest fight he
could take it that way you know whatever
but people that don't know that would be
like what do you think puppy is better
than the other guys at that level I
would say it's him I would say it's slim
and I would say it's Gibb if I
realistically said who would make the
most sense and people aren't going to
like this answer but it would be Gibb
absolutely bro
man I am down for that and it's not
because I want to see these two friends
punch each other but what the [__] do we
have in Misfits if not for storylines
the storyline that these two friends
used to spar each other literally
started boxing together and now oh and
you give wants a lot of money there's a
way to pay a month and money and not
only that it's like it's such an
exciting fight for me like because you
know how tough these two Lads are I know
and you know them both but let's not
let's not act like these two are just
lifelong mates because what I'm starting
to learn is there's some healthy
competition between absolutely like when
they've they've you know had their spars
and things like that and I don't know
what's happened in those bars or who's
gotten the better who I don't know
that'll have to be something that one
day we maybe find out but what I do see
is just on that but I don't know how
true this is this is just you know you
hear certain things of like the last
spot that they had before Juju went off
and did his own thing very competitive
see what I'm saying you know so yeah
this is another reason that we need to
have this and again it's a it's a fact a
growing since then and you know right
but yeah but again a consistent give the
entire time I mean I talked to Vidal
Riley he says Gibb is either watching
Cobra Kai and playing with his cats or
boxing and that's it you know give is
just that dude he's in the gym all the
time but I'll say this
when when Gibb has a fight and let's go
back to the Austin fight when he won the
first thing KSI was saying was congrats
but the second thing he was saying was
I'd still beat him you know it's like
okay well if that's the case and there
was also a call that happened right
after that fight where man's Taylor and
Liam chippers were on the call and they
were like yo you want to set this thing
up like what are we doing and it was
kind of jokey kind of you know whatever
it was on Twitter I think people
remember but at the same time there's
something there it's like right now I I
tell you I can't explain how much more
excited I would be for Gib KSI than I
would for Dylan Dennis KSI yeah ten
times more because you know it's good
and again one of the other things is we
you've you've rightly talked about the
progression
Jake Paul thought Gib and and he beat
him very convincingly in that fight but
Gibb's done a lot of growing since time
but there's there's that as well you
know what I mean you know there's a
reason to go well I'm gonna fight every
guy you fought for example fight game
fight Tyron Woodley and and and compare
up again he could easily do that if he
wanted to and in the mean a win versus
game now would mean so much more than it
meant when Jake and not to say that Jake
was was like Jake can't control that he
beat a guy that was still early and Jake
was still early but now watching the
evolution of Gibb that would mean a ton
more and think about it stylistically
just really quickly they're both the
same fighter essentially
except give is probably I mean listen
I'm gonna be honest he might be a little
more technically sound than JJ at least
than what we've seen that's the problem
we haven't seen we're still waiting on
that performance from JJ the great
performance
um because obviously the Logan ones are
very Scrappy the last ones weren't uh a
challenge whereas Gibb's last fight was
arguably the best YouTube boxing fight
I've watched in terms of entertainment
and and the way he came back and decked
this guy was uh tremendous
um by the way JJ not being as
technically sound as Gib doesn't mean
[__] if JJ and again we talk about
Styles making matchups if JJ's able to
just Mo give down and put him on a back
foot that would be interesting to see
too because we haven't really seen it
since the Jake fight How would how would
Gibb react to being pushed backward over
and over and over right these are things
that we would love to see I'm just
saying I know people don't want that
fight they're like oh they're friends
put that fight together and you want to
see some pay-per-view well that'll do it
and and then you've got a fighter in
front of KSI who is legitimately
bringing something to the table that
actually adds weight to the situation on
a social level on a boxing level Gibb
takes every single box maybe not as much
as a Logan Paul but in in this industry
what are you looking for you know what I
mean it's it's it's Gabe it's a Taywood
if the table's asking for too much money
I think he's a great challenge yeah
that's the one if you're talking about a
talent level Gibb is right there with
slam he's right there with salt poppy
but if you're talking about the social
level the fandom he he blows both those
guys out of the water right now you
tweeted out recently about deji that um
you think you know what his next move
might be I'm excited because I feel like
deji is highly underused at the moment
like even he's just had that fight with
Floyd at I feel like that should
catapult him into new things I'll ask
you this and it'll be interesting to see
what you think here what would you do
with deji right now
I think you need winnable fights for him
because he is such a superstar in this
uh environment however his fighting
skills are
still
raw and and there's some Talent there
but you know he has lost a lot of fights
so you have to pick wisely there's
people like Bryce Hall who would be a
really nice matchup for him I've always
wanted to see Joe Weller get back in the
ring and I think size wise him and
deji'd be a good competition but I don't
know if deji's had too much boxing
experience at this point but those are
the kind of match-ups I'd be looking at
winnable but exciting yeah I agree with
you I think that those would be great
matchups but
here's where I I think that we we're
going to get Daddy next so I I've been
doing the old research uh Wade kind of
deal on my channel and the video is
actually coming out today so hopefully
it'll you guys will get more insight but
I've been talking I've been I got
sources now I got multiple sources now
I've been talking to people and I'm just
trying to figure this thing out because
veggie put out a video a couple days ago
and right at the end of the video one of
the fans asking hey when are you
fighting again and all he says is March
boom and the video clicks off I was like
hmm okay and so happy punch picked it up
and they put some names down right who
could he be fighting next and they had
Bryce they had Jay swingler they had
Alex Wassabi two which is true that
would be great swingler and then they
had Liam Payne on that on that uh no
[__] way now listen to me give me a
second here okay
deji just fought Floyd Mayweather
on global Titans correct yeah if you're
gonna have deji fight anyone else and I
spoke with deji after that fight and I
even talked to him about kind of what
his mindset was
and one of the things he told me was
these guys are gonna have to chase me
now
and I thought okay that means deji is
now in his mind and probably rightfully
so head of the table when it comes to
influencer boxing because he just fought
Floyd now he thinks and rightfully so he
deserves that main event spot he's
definitely a name he's definitely top
five names in the in the sport
regardless of losses yeah now when you
talk about where deji could fight
Misfits is an option but let's think
about it again we're talking about the
money issues right
is deji gonna be a guy that they can not
say a Ford but a guy that they're
willing to take that chance on in a main
event setting
because quite frankly I watched the deji
and Floyd fight I was there but not many
people other than the people in that
Arena watched it at least not through
pay-per-view nah
oh it did I know it did do you know how
many it did I did under 100K uh and and
I don't I don't know the exact number
but it was under that oh that hurts that
that hurts his fault but it's like they
paid Floyd [__] Mayweather short yeah
Floyd Mayweather Mr Alta all time uh
he's the one who should be carrying the
production and the promotion rather like
this guy turned up like just just Grace
with his presence I didn't hear what was
going on behind the scenes with Floyd is
trying to save it yeah it was awful but
that leaves me
with what you said a guy that deji can
possibly beat
but is again low risk High reward and
elevates his name it's got to be a
celebrity Jordan it has to be and I
don't think it's going to be on Misfits
I think he's going to go and fight again
on global Titans
and I think he's going to do it in the
UK
and I if I'm putting a prediction out
there it's Liam Payne it's 100 Liam
Payne
but think about it if he's living my
dream he's punching Floyd he's punching
One Direction
I'm so jealous of you it's like if they
do it here's here's why I say that I
have no confirmation of this at all I'm
putting pieces together but Liam Payne
wants to fight KSI right if he
legitimately wants to be a reckless man
like he was talking on Logan's podcast
and he wants to fight KSI and he wants
to feel that adrenaline the stupidest
[__] I've ever heard but if he wants to
do that
what better way to get to it than going
through this little brother Liam Payne
though when he talks he reminds me oh
and I watch a lot of crime shows he
reminds me of like a sociopathic serial
killer like he has this thing where he's
completely out of touch with reality and
like has so much self-belief and
self-love
um I would not put it past him to be in
the ring like for this reason because
the guy obviously adores himself uh
you're gonna have to be able to afford
him you're gonna have to be able to not
and I keep saying it forward I'm selling
records anymore like his career has
pretty much [__] from what I can under
I'm not a music guy but right he's not
like he's not like the other one with a
long [__] Harry Styles yeah he's not
that cool but what I'm saying
what I'm saying is he is
used to be a part of One Direction so
his masking price is going to be Astro
those girls will turn up they will be
cheering for him
but who's gonna pay that astronomical
asking price who's already done it
before it's Global Titans I don't I
genuinely don't know if they care about
making money I don't think they do so if
you do that yeah you put your [__]
commentary fee up that's for sure oh bro
yeah I don't 100 need to yeah people
knew what I got paid for that
um
let's just say it was not great so if
they do it in the UK
that fight would be massive so you're
going to be doing wrestling content on
your uh Channel coming up I'm I'm
excited to see that because I'm I'm an
old school wrestling guy obviously I've
interviewed a few of those Legends The
Undertaker
um sorry sorry sorry it's just crazy
stuff you're doing with that I love it
um and you know we were talking about
influencer boxing it makes sense to talk
about Logan's Talent as a wrestler
because I've seen Shawn Michaels and a
quote from him to say
after watching three wrestling matches
from Logan Paul it's the most talented
three wrestling matches guy he's ever
seen or something along those lines and
I thought yeah it makes sense so what do
you make of Logan's time in the ring so
far man you talk about guys that just
get the business like you can see the
difference even in not this isn't like
making fun of Jake but you see the
difference in who gets it and who
doesn't Logan just gets it right there's
there's a quote out there I think Jim
cornette uh talked about watching Rocky
my via the rock for the first time just
running the ropes in an Old Farm he was
training and he was like that's gonna be
the WWE Champion in three years that's
the guy right there you just you know it
when you see it Logan has these
qualities if Sean Michael is one of the
best in-ring performers we've ever seen
is putting that crown on his head and
saying that guy's got it you might see
Logan Paul
I listen I'm not gonna be one of those
guys that just pulls out a hot take but
I could see two three four years down
the line if he wants to do this him
walking around with a WWE Champion man
you know that last WrestleMania where
they brought back Stone Cold yes I did a
video around that time and Logan had
only had one one I think he had his
first match on that week yeah yeah and I
said they should have done Logan versus
Stone Cold it would have blew the
[__] roof off because it's it's
literally like Floyd versus Logan it's
the same [__] really you know what I
mean it's the same idea and I had so
much hate from wrestling fans he doesn't
belong in there Kevin Owens is the one
who should have and I was like you'll
see because I could say after that one
match even there was something special
there and now he's already main evented
against the moment where he's vlogging
himself flying off the [__] turnbook
all into the table six this is what
people don't realize wrestling is about
being over wrestling is about connecting
with the fans and making people feel
this is why mjf and aew is one of the
best stars in the in the can you explain
about this guy because I see him I have
no I've never seen this guy wrestle all
I see is his promos and I'm I'm watching
them like
I've seen him in William Regal I want to
call uh yeah Henry and forth and I was
like this is actually entertaining like
this is not the [__] I've been
seeing served up from years ago this
this reminds me of raw early 2000s yes
and and the reason you feel that Jordy
is because he makes you feel that right
it's not [__] you know comedy it's
not goofy wrestling with pre-written
story lines where guys are just talking
about whatever was written and handed to
them in a script and there's no emotion
and those there's no feeling behind it
mjf Blends the lines between is this
real does he really feel this way about
William Regal did William Regal really
piss him off to this point and oh [__] I
might be getting worked here but you
don't care because you're in the moment
watching a guy that sounds real that
sounds like it comes from his heart yeah
talk about the things that have happened
to him he is the most legitimate guy
that we have in the scene just like when
when the stone cold thing first kicked
off it was all about how raging he was
about getting sucked by w say w and that
Venom that was in his heart just spilled
out all over the camera and you could
feel how legitimately angry he was when
you can identify with the normal man
when you can identify with people's real
emotions then wrestling becomes fun
because now we're lost in the sauce now
we are enthralled in what's happening so
we'll watch A Match where we know man
the backstory of this thing is this guy
[__] hates this other guy or he's a
bad guy because William Regal all those
years ago told him that he wasn't ready
so I kind of want to see if he's ready
and then you get lost in that so the
match itself becomes even more fun when
there's not doing 25 different flips and
someone's landing on their back then
springing to their feet not selling a
damn thing no it's a story being told
through physical action mjf's the best
at it Logan's very very good at it
already and that's what makes wrestling
fun I enjoy watching guys that care
about the steam care about the sport of
wrestling like I I'm still one of those
guys I'm the old dude in the high school
gym that's like it's still real to me
Dave that's that's me dude who was the
guy who who when you were watching were
they I mean were they specific people
who really made you fall in love with
this thing yeah absolutely when I when I
first started watching wrestling Shawn
Michaels was the guy that made me fall
in love absolutely I watched this guy
you know he was a baby behind the scenes
he wasn't a baby face but he was a baby
face in the ring that would just get
beaten Pillar To Post he would sell he
would do the running carry it into the
turnbuckle and fly off and he had this
great body language and then he would
find a way to win he would come back
from underneath he would take down the
big guy when he was doing the matches
with Vader you're like how the F how the
hell is he gonna be Vader this dude's
massively 300 pound but that was what
got me into to wrestling and when I
started to see the rise of the Rock and
I started to see all of the the stuff
with stone cold it was just it took it
over the edge right and so from that
point I really got on board with it and
then I started to see the business go
more toward the entertainment of
children children and that's where it
kind of lost me a bit but yeah it's
starting to come back with a guy named
njf I'm telling you he's the best of the
biz I've heard about him having a
contract uh coming to an end or
something leading war of 2024 That's it
man so and again this is what's so cool
is is he's able to blend reality with a
little bit of kfabe he's starting to
show you guys there's no there's nothing
off limits I'm in character always I'm
in I'm in kfave always he's talking
about going to Patty pimlet and fighting
him in the UFC bringing his title belt
he is like I said when it comes 2024
he's going to be the most coveted free
agent in all of wrestling yeah I think
it's great that this is uh and it sounds
like Triple H after everything that went
on with Vince McMahon in his big Scandal
which was the least surprising boss
shagging work and Scandal of all time uh
it seems like Triple H is trying to
bring back what we all loved about it
once upon a time he's trying it's going
to be interesting to see if Triple H can
do it he did a little bit with NXT
getting back to focused match based
content where guys are it makes sense
why they're having a match the match
makes sense dudes aren't just flipping
around and you know 30 minutes of just
non-stop like meth head running around
addict there's actual reasons why
they're fighting the reasons they're
fighting lead into the match and the
story lines don't just end when the
match is over these things continue to
go long-term booking I hope that Triple
H can do it because the debt the the
wrestling business desperately needs it
they desperately need like we're on our
like it's it's hard to say because
socials and everything's going crazy and
the WWE he's never going to go away but
we're on our last breath as a wrestling
business as far as the public sees it we
need to make a comeback and I think
that's what's happening with again I
have to go right to mjf because the rest
of aw is struggling a bit but the WWE if
they can rewrite this ship can
absolutely bring it back to something
that people love
well big songs to you we're grateful for
the time brother and I'm looking forward
to seeing uh you next month when you're
in town mate we'll uh we'll do another
one of these or something after the
event should we do a review
yeah I'm down all right cool we'll get
you in the studio after the event man uh
big love to the weird concept he's
trying to get the 300 000 subscribers do
subscribe to him I've been around on his
channel since what 5K or something I
can't remember
I'm an org man uh so yeah don't forget
to check with Channel out thanks very
much and we'll see you on the next one
cheers